estamos en la en casa de nariño donde se
ha producido la reunión entre el
secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken y el presidente de colombia iván
duque una oportunidad para que ambos
mandatarios hayan destacado las buenas
relaciones que tienen históricamente
ambos países pero también una
oportunidad para mandar un mensaje
global y multilateral a la región para
unir fuerzas para combatir problemas
como el kobe 19 o también el cambio
climático y especial énfasis han hecho
en la migración para que los dos han
señalado que hay que actuar al corto
plazo pero también al largo plazo y
evitar con creación de oportunidades
esas caravanas que se han visto en los
últimos años tanto de migrantes
centroamericanos como venezolanos en los
más recientes y los haitianos también ha
habido especial momento para hablar de
la paz la implementación de los acuerdos
de paz firmados en 2016 entre el estado
y la guerrilla de las farc estados
unidos mediante anthony blinken se han
mostrado muy comprometidos con este
proceso pero también han hablado de la
situación de derechos humanos en
colombia especialmente por las denuncias
de human rights watch mediante jose
miguel me bancó su director para las
américas de vulneración de derechos
humanos durante las manifestaciones
inicia el pasado 28 de abril que
sacudieron al país y anthony blinken ha
instado al estado colombiano a respetar
los derechos humanos pero también a que
se respeten la democracia en colombia